we need stories we need stories to
understand ourselves
[Music]
we are the only creature that does this
unusual thing
of telling each other stories in order
to try and understand the kind of
creature that we are
when a child is born the first thing the
child
requires is safety and love
the next thing that the child asks for
is tell me a story
i've been writing now for over 50 years
and this is the first time i've done
anything like this
you will learn the lessons i had to find
out the hard way
character plot dialogue rhythm i do
think language has a musicality there's
all this stuff about three act structure
exactly how you must allow a story to
unfold my view is it's all nonsense
the first and only rule is be
interesting make it as vivid as you can
as an exercise write 300 words about the
place
without using any adjectives if you
can't say that somewhere is beautiful
or green what it forces you to do
is to tell a story about it
[Music]
i'm going to read from this manuscript i
wrote in my mid-twenties
it was a failure so much so that i never
showed it to anybody until this
ah the sky is nude today encasing his
documentary in a very un-february blue
you see i don't even know what that's
about
i had a very bumpy start and to be frank
i wrote a lot of garbage
part of the reason why i was lost is
that i had grown up in one culture and i
was living in another
and i didn't quite understand my
relationship with either
i really needed to work out who i was
because if you're not clear about who
you
are then you're not clear about how to
write
whatever you write right because it
comes from some very deep place inside
you that you really really really need
to express just make sure that you don't
stop till you get to the end
i'm salman rushdie and this is my
masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
you